gamer's are here in a lot of terms
thrown around lately like vr HDR and 4k
over the years there have been many
attempts at using peripherals and
formats to improve the core gaming
experience some of them successful like
rumble packs and directional sound some
of them not so much like 3d televisions
voice commands and fake instruments with
that in mind I decided to throw a few
shooters at a peripheral I've always
wanted to try a 21 by 9 LG ultra wide
curved gaming monitor battlefield 1
fired up without a problem
there were some strangeness going from
the main menu to 21 by 9 and the first
time you're confronted with that much
screen real estate it's a bit jarring
this aspect ratio is designed to display
cinema scope or the more modern
anamorphic format more commonly what you
would find in a movie theater but when
watching a movie you naturally pan your
eyes left and right in a shooter you
want to focus intensely on the
crosshairs at the center so you have to
get used to using the corners of the
monitor as peripheral vision and resist
the urge to constantly look away from
your aim point I also had to turn up
aimed sensitivity a bit to swing all the
way left and right to hit targets at the
edge of my screen
that being said peripheral vision was
great I can keep tabs on multiple flags
at a time in conquest to see if the
enemy team was pushing without having to
move my mouse to check more than once I
was repairing a vehicle and caught
someone trying to sneak up on me with an
80 grenade no you don't there were
instant benefits to situational
awareness and also a greater enjoyment
of the beauty and grit of battlefield
ones destructible environments the next
important test was Rainbow six siege a
game all about situational awareness
which should play to the strengths of
ultra wide which turned out to mostly be
the case one of the drawbacks of the
extra information on screen is that
there are more things to distract you
from that tiny head in the corner behind
the bookcase about to shoot you a good
player could probably accomplish the
same level of situational awareness with
a good surround sound headset and
increased field of view one strange bit
though was having to tweak the field of
view because one side above 80 in
Rainbow six siege the edges of the
screen have a fisheye lens effect that I
was hoping would disappear on an ultra
wide monitor but it didn't
the last game that I tried was titanfall
too much like Battlefield the wider view
of maps greatly added to my appreciation
of their design titanfall pioneered the
easy wall run where players can skim
along surfaces without actually having
to look at them but with ultra wide I
became more aware of movement options
and what enemy pilots were doing around
me while I was parkouring or farming
grunts when in Titans you just get a lot
more cockpit which gives you a greater
sense of being inside of a machine which
is pretty damn cool at the end of my
ultra wide experience I tried a few
things that concern me playing a game
letterbox in sixteen by nine turns out
it wasn't the distraction I thought it
would be
there were a few weird compatibility
issues such as Skyrim worked but Skyrim
special edition didn't not all games are
compatible with 21 by 9 but I was left
feeling that if you're looking to buy a
2 monitor setup anyway a curved
ultrawide monitor may run in the same
price range and could make your shooter
experiences that much better overall
ultra-wide gaming check the boxes of
what a good peripheral does mainly
something that enhances your gaming
experience and if you remove it you feel
like something's missing
at the end of my experience with the
ultrawide monitor I know that I'm gonna
have a hard time going back to 16 by 9
stop